[موسيقى]
28 هدف وعليه 17 رجب سوره اسيا عام 1991
ابطال الدوري فكان له وقعه عليه شخصيه
فرحتنا فيه لا يمكن انساها
لاعب نادي الهلال سابقا
فوق العروس المرمى
لعب الكره داخل المرمى
سوق التمياط
نادي الهلال لهذا الانجاز على مستوى قاره
اسيا الله يبارك
في الرياض كان خيالي
يتوقع لك الكثير مستقبل باهر في كره القدم
ولكن يعاب على صفوف انه الكثير المراوقه
الامر الذي يؤدي الى اصلاح
حاولت حاولت
سبحان الله
فضلت الابتعاد
ولدت في مدينه رفحاء بيئه اجتماعيه ما لها
اي مجال في الرياض ولا حب الرياضه شاهدت
التلفزيون صدفه احببت شيء اسمه نادي
الهلال
الميلاديه
يعني اللاعبين حلقت في الهلال
[تصفيق]
عبد العزيز درسنا في المرحله الابتدائيه
انا ومحمد فخذنا المباراه ضد بدرة ثانية
كان عندي مفاجاه
احنا عارفين لعبنا مباراه فيزا على
المدرسه قال اللي حاضر المباراه المدرب
واختاركم انتم المدرسه الهلال
[موسيقى]
ممارستنا الرياضه غالبا مدرسه الهلال
الكرويه اللي تقريب العام 1980 ميلادي
ويمكن التاريخ حنا ساعدنا وسمى مدرسه
الهلال الكرويه عشان نقنع المرحوم ونقضي
على
مدرسه الهلال
يعني
قلنا لهم احنا ما راح نكمل بس نبغى نروح
نضيع وقت لكن انا كنت يعني محب نادي
الهلال
وكنت اتمنى اني ارتدي شعار نادي الهلال
لعب بطوله الخليج الناشئين في الكويت
اللي كانت نقل نوعيه حياه الرياضيه
التلفزيون
تغيرت حياه نهائيا علي سجلت في النهائي
ومحمد اخوي البطوله
[موسيقى]
محمد اللي حققنا بطوله شباب الهلال
وناشئين على مستوى المملكه بينها يومين
لعب وسجل هدف وفزعه وانا من بكره شباب
الهلال من الملعب ولا يسار
[موسيقى]
شوي نسرع في الامور على اول نظارات مع
الفريق الاول
صبيح اللي كنت اتابعهم على عمري ها العب
معهم
حسين
امس قاعد اتابع الحين
[موسيقى]
دوري
تلعبنا تصفيات بطول العرب
[موسيقى]
ما تسمع زميلك داخل الملعب
احيانا بعض اللاعبين تقولي كيف ضيع فرصه
انا اتكلم بشكل عام ولا كيف شات الكره فوق
هذا ترى من شد نفسي عدم توافق الذهني
والعضلي
حضور صاحب الجماهير والصلاه الجماهير فعلا
كانت فيها نديه اكثر
[موسيقى]
لصالح فريق المهوره السوداني
على الارض ان شاء الله يقوم بالسلامه
سلامات
تذليل جميع الصعوبات
وتاهلنا فيها قبل ما العب اول دوري
[موسيقى]
جديد علينا
نلعب ضد فريق النهضه في الرياض
والاصابه جت اول ست ثواني مع اول البدايه
جت الاصابه
ودوني المستشفى الاسعاف
حطوا لي جبس رجعت
مباراه القدم ما قدرت اتجاوزها بس تعالج
في البرازيل
اثرت عليه كثير صراحه هذه اول اصابه ترى
فتره التعافي من الاصابه اخذت فتره طويله
بعد ما فضيت فتره
استعداد وانك ترجع وتشارك
محمد جاء قطع في العضله الاماميه الفخذ
يعني انفصل الركبه
[موسيقى]
الى الان اثرها موجود
طبعا
انا ما حد يسالك
الهلال يعني اصبرت عليه كثير من كثر
الاصابات الفتره هذه يتكلم بعد عام 92
ميلادي اتذكر الطبيب النادي
كان يقول اهم شيء اللاعب بعد الاصابه اول
اشتراك
يتعدى نفسيا مرحله الخوف
يمكن عشر مرات
فيبدا التاهيل التاهيل بوتين
[موسيقى]
كدمه يمر على غرفه
تعالج
تشوف ناديك يلعب وتشوف كذا ودك يجيك حماس
انك تكون معهم
الموضوع
يطرح نفسه كيف ماشي الاصابه الان والطريق
وطبعا متق العضله الخلفيه
فكنت مرحله انه يلعبون الشوط الثاني
ويشوفون كيف
فلعبت ورجعت لي في نفس المباراه
اذا كانت الاصابه قديمه
الى كان اعتقد رجعت بعد فتره اعداد طويله
[موسيقى]
ثم انسى طبعا دعم الجمهور صبر الجمهور
فضلت النيه
ما اكمل
فتره طويله يعني الفرصه لغيرك يخدمها
الفريق حاولت حاولت تكرار الاصابات كان
مؤثر جدا
[موسيقى]
لعبه حلوه
اتذكر حتى شافه مدرب
كان يدربنا صغير
بالكوره
سواك نواف
وراح يتفرج على نواف هذا راح كله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا ولد عشان كذا متذكر انها
لاعب شباب الهلال
اول تمرين
[موسيقى]
سجل اليوم الظهر وقع
التمرين اليوم الاول
والله كان دخل عليه ما سهره قال
كان صغير هو
ثاني رباط صليبي انا ذهلت كنت استشير
الاطباء وكذا طمني طبيب النادي بن ابوك
قال اخوك صغير في السنه
[موسيقى]
يعني مرحله
عمل عمليه ورجع ما شاء الله
امام المرمى
ممتاز
[موسيقى]
تكرار اصابات
اثر عليها لكن يؤثر على زيت اكثر كيف كان
واحد انه يلعب في النادي يملك مهارات
فرديه يعني
امي اعترضت قال تكفيني ثلاثه كل شي واحد
دخل عليه في عكاز وواحد عصابه وواحد مسافر
برازيلي يسوي عمليه فيازيد
ارجوك والله تعبت انا ابغى ارتاح
[موسيقى]
مستقبلك وبالعكس وفرحت فعلا راح زيد
صادف بعد سفر زيد بثلاثه اشهر احدث سبتمبر
[تصفيق]
3000 كمسلمين الموجودين هناك مضايقات كل
العالم عارف الوضع خاصه في اول الازمه
يوميا كلمه في اليوم اكثر من مره اتكلم
معي اتصلت عليه اخر مره كانت زين
ارجع ارجع لو تبي تلعب في اي نادي
[موسيقى]
تخيل لو مثلا عامة
اخر يوم مثلا جت اصابه قالوا خلاص
يعني ما كنت فجاه صراحه
شبهه ويعني مهير عشان كذا وقعها علي عقل
[موسيقى]
الى الان الى الان اثار الاصابات موجوده
الى الان
على انك دخلت الكوره
واستمريت فيها رياضي بشكل عام لا والله
بالعكس
يعني تجربه مميزه بالنسبه في حياتي ما
ندمت عليها صراحه بالعكس التجربه اهتز
فيها كثير عندي
[موسيقى]
حارس المرمى الله شفت كلمتك تلعب فعلا هذه
تعذب كثير
يعني
لو تسال اي لاعب اعتزل صعب
اي لاعب معتزل لحظات لم يشوف فريقه يلعب
وجات كذا يعني ما كنا أول تشنج ليش الدوره
اللي عليك تاديه في الملعب
لكن ما استطعت مثل الفريق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]